finishing Today's Show with yet another
update in the Brian coburger Saga
student and employment records were
released from the accused quadruple
killer School District where he worked
as a security guard up until just two
years ago according to the documents
coburger's Security Supervisor at
Pleasant Valley School District in
Pennsylvania considered him to be
reserved courteous polite and even
reliable coburger graduated from that
same district in 2013. in 2018 he was
even credited with helping save the life
of a staff member having a medical
emergency as part of the job coburger
would report unarmed to the district to
work eight-hour security shifts on the
weekend making sure all school buildings
were locked in working order records
show that he resigned from the position
in 2021 after working there for five
years coburger wrote in his resignation
letter that he decided to leave quote
freely and voluntarily after considering
his options since coburger's arrest
coburger's Alma moderate DeSales
University released a statement but his
Pennsylvania school district has
remained silent all of their requested
it records were from a court ordered
subpoena but it's unclear whether the
prosecution or the defense requested
them this all due to a gag order that
has been put in place by the judge so
Brian why would either side want these
high school records they're almost a
decade old so Jesse they're either going
to be a window into who co-burger is and
was if it's a prosecution saying hey
look he was quiet and reserved and he
was exactly what we would think the type
of person or they may even go even
further the type of animal would do this
type of quadruple murder or for the
defense they would say hey this is
completely out of character look he
saved someone's life he was always about
security was always about taking care of
people around him who they are trying to
portray Brian coburger isn't who he is
based on his history maybe they got the
wrong guy I think it's going to come
down to some level of character or
relevance based on the crimes and either
side will have their pick as to whether
or not it helps or hurts them but if it
hurts more than it helps they may both
want to try to stay away from any kind
of character evidence in this case let
me throw another theory out here because
I think that they want the records of
him at least as a security guard to say
listen this is a guy who knew how to you
know check all the perimeters see all
the security track his steps you know
this is somebody you might be saying if
he was really stalking the victims he we
can kind of understand how he learned
this I mean he was really working there
the year before this happened that's my
take on maybe they want to know his
actions as a security guard still think
it's a little bit of a stretch but hey
that's my take so Terry I'll move to you
the district didn't release all of the
records on coburger why wouldn't they do
that you know I think they're playing
it's safe first of all there is a
federal law it's called the family
educational rights and Privacy Act and
what that does it protects school
records now remember he was working at
the school district but he was also a
student at the school district so just
think about your records from school you
need to get permission before those
records are released and that's what the
school district wanted to do they wanted
to send a notice even though he was in
jail at the time to get those records
released so they went through that
process they thought it was important to
do that the other issue as far as the
employment records are concerned they
cannot release everything think about it
name rank and serial number is generally
what you're going to get as far as
employment records are concerned they
cannot in any way shape or form give any
sort of non-criminal Investigation
especially if it didn't end up in
resulting in some issue as far as the
employee is concerned and so they're not
going to release all of that either what
they did release I think both you and
Brian are right they can use it for or
against him just you know learning the
back story of Brian coburger Brian Terry
thank you so much everyone out there
thanks for joining us here on the daily
we're going to see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
foreign
[Music]